- I don't know anything about cricket.
- There's no real crickets in it.
("Four Seasons - Spring")
- The bat is called a wicket.
- The wicket's the ball I believe.
- When I think about cricket I think about
the outfits that they're wearing.
Shorts and like a jacket or
something. It seems very proper.
- So I guess there's a lot of different
accessories for your cricket outfit.
The entire time that we have
been talking about cricket
I've been envisioning croquet.
- It's like squash had
a baby with baseball.
- So green is Pakistan, blue is India.
- There's someone wearing blue,
there's someone wearing red
and there's someone wearing black
and I think only two teams playing.
- There's a cowboy on the field.
- Is that a Mountie?
- That must be the ref.
- He looks like a Canadian Mountie.
- He's definitely not called
an umpire, I know that.
- Home run! I think.
- What are the bars in the middle?
- That's a sign.
That's a sign. This means something.
- I'm not really sure where the bases are.
Still have no clue how
they acquire points.
- It's like there are no outfielders.
So maybe the goal is
not to catch the ball.
- He's trying to hit the
ball along the ground.
Well then, why were they so excited
before when they went far away?
- I have no idea what's going on here.
This is very confusing.
- Where are they trying to get the ball?
It feels like it can go anywhere.
- He said that was a lovely shot.
It rolled towards a line
that looked like a
warning track in baseball.
- I know less now about cricket
than I knew before we watched it.
- I think it looks dope.
- I don't even know how
many rounds there are.
Like how many points you need to win.
- We didn't even know
what they were doing.
- I'm definitely not going
to look out for it on ESPN.
- Any sport with cowboys
could probably easily
become second nature to me eventually.